but I'm going to play Mark Cuban's
comments for you Chris mark was with his
first hour and I don't know if you've
heard an owner admit to attacking the
strategy here's Mark Cuban first hour in
the show problem is if you know you're
in rebuild then you tank super early and
you lose your games early so that you
get eliminated from the playoffs early
and get more ping-pong balls but I don't
know if you're going to be that good
that you're going to be winning games if
your 10th you know you're not that good
in the first window but yeah I mean it's
like look you know we all deal the Mavs
once we were eliminated from the
playoffs we did everything possible to
lose games and so if we did it upfront
if we knew that this is a rebuild season
and we just did it upfront then you know
you you know you kind of know what kind
of team you have and if you could get
eliminated early and then start building
momentum you can finish you know your
season 30 and 10 and end up with a
boatload of ping-pong balls how did you
tank how do you get all your young
players ok that was it but there is is
it you send out a memo or you just say
no no because the guys once a guy walks
on the court they're gonna play the hard
out particularly the young guys because
they have something to prove so you know
Dorian finney-smith yogi Ferrell there
there's nothing you could say or do to
them to say don't play hard or try to
lose this game that wouldn't be right
and I don't think any NBA team would
ever do that but when you have solid
mezra shooting threes that's not a good
thing yeah spring in Chris Mannix your
reaction well it's refreshing honestly
Dan and you know he's putting voice to
something that anybody that covers the
NBA knows that that this is exactly how
teams tank and you know being honest I
don't really have a problem with with
that philosophy if you want to roll out
your young players give them extended
minutes there is an upside to that in
addition to losing games you could also
develop them so what the Mavericks did I
don't really have a problem with what
the Lakers did I didn't necessarily have
that big a problem with it was what the
Phoenix Suns did that I had a big
problem with when you have you know
young ish high salary players like Eric
Bledsoe and Ben Brandon Knight sitting
there on your bench when your coach is
saying that the reason they're not
playing is because it's a management
decision that's basically throwing it in
the face of the NBA so you know I I'm
impressed that Cuba would go there I
would imagine that somebody in the
entity often you might be reaching out
to him at some point but he's he's
telling the the God's honest truth and
even at the end where he says you can't
tell young players the tanki's right you
know everyone that goes out there is
going to play you just get to determine
who goes out there does it
all right Celtics have a good dilemma
here where they're a good team with the
number one overall pick
give me the scenarios of what you think
Danny Ainge is a fielding right now yeah
I was in the drawing room
last night then and their combination
came up three consecutive times so a
basketball gods were determined to give
Boston number one uh you know look III
think Danny in the Celtics I think
they're going to take marquel folks if
it was number two three or four I would
be more inclined to believe that a trade
could be on the horizon I think they
like but don't love Lonzo ball I think
they like but don't love the combination
of Josh Jackson and Jason Batum I think
there are a lot of people in the
organization of love marquel folks that
believe that he is a franchise point
guard and I mean nobody's untradable but
it would be it would be almost
impossible I think at this point to
extract that number one pick from Boston
just because of how the organization
thinks about folks all right well then
that brings me to Isaiah Thomas who
you're scoring 29 a game you're the real
deal here and if you're going to draft
somebody who is a scoring point guard
can you coexist have those two coexist
do you extend Isaiah Thomas after 2018
in paying thirty forty million dollars a
year well it the question is is this
summer of course and do you give him
that same type of extension that Russell
Westbrook received last summer local my
city that's what Isaiah wants he's
playing underage
incredibly slow number for a player of
his caliber but Boston
I don't think Boston wants to give Isiah
Thomas that type of money right now
Boston craves cap flexibility at this
moment they've got a lot of good
contracts on this roster and the guy
they want to nab this summer is Gordon
Hayward they want to use that cap
flexibility and go out and get Gordon
Hayward and potentially package some of
their their secondary players guys in
that kind of Marcus smart Bunch but
maybe even see if they can get Jimmy
Butler out of Chicago if they give Isiah
Thomas an extension before all these big
deals are done for this happens they
lose their cap flexibility they can't do
all the things that what they want to do
so I think Danny Ainge I get the sense
that they're the most likely scenario
here is that they go to Isaiah they
think I said marquel falsify together
they don't think that you have to have
one without the other but I think
they're going to go to Isaiah and say
look we want to pay you we're going to
pay you but you might have to wait until
your contract is up at the end of 1718
to get all the money that you want
alright the Lakers their dilemma if
there is a dilemma as long as the
Celtics don't do anything goofy up top
then launch a ball falls in their lap is
long so ball the right player for this
team yeah I think he is it's you know
Rob kolenka was representing the Lakers
with drawing room and when that number
came up at do and they look like the
weight of the world just came off and
shoulders I mean but you know you know
the scenarios of course if they fell
outside that top three not just with
this year but but 2019 and getting that
pick I mean that opens up a whole wealth
of options now they III think they're
locked in on ball I mean they were not
tipping their hand at this point but
everything points in that direction I
think that's the right place for Lonzo
to I mean he can play alongside with the
Angelo Russell offense for where they
want to go in that lineup and and with
Magic Johnson's presence in LA you know
that's going to make the Lavar ball
factor a little bit less of a pressing
concerns
I mean Lavar has to respect magics
authority there nearly he wasn't look as
much as what bars kind of this
distraction right now he really wasn't
last year for the UCLA team so I think
being
this environment it's good for Lonzo off
the court and I think that Lakers team
is going to get for them on the court
but this team getting younger they need
to have a little more seasoning there
feels like you know we keep talking
about Randall and Ingram and DeAngelo
Russell Clarkson you know they need
something else here besides Alonzo ball
at the point
I agree but but they're not going to get
it this summer you know they're they're
preserving all this cap space for next
year we all know the store debt we know
who is a free agent 2018 we know Paul
George has expressed a desire to play in
LA we know that Russell Westbrook right
now can be a free agent 2018 has ties
there I mean the Lakers are not going to
sacrifice their caps flexibility this
summer to bring in veterans that might
help them win a few games this year in
fact what I think is going to happen in
the next couple of months few months
maybe even into next season is you're
going to see the Lakers they are a hard
push maybe even including a young player
as an incentive to move one of those big
contracts they've got on the roster be
the Timofey Mozgov deal is an albatross
already around their neck they have no
use for Luol Deng anymore you know I
think they're going to be aggressively
tried to move those contracts to clear
even more flexibility for 2018 I I don't
see the Lakers on veteran shopping this
summer I think this year is going to be
focused on the development of the young
guys on the roster and next years when
they put their their foot in the water
thank you Chris you got it then that's
Chris Mannix yahoos the vertical
covering the lottery last night the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience